I'm dividing this this chapter up into
three main sections just throwing so
much stuff at you but I think it might
be helpful they have these broad
designations to put things under in this
chapter do you ever have one of those
those answer uncles or cousins who has a
bit of a tea to eat when they're talking
to you and we're trying to bring you up
to speed and everything that's happened
that's the way this chapter kind of
feels they're just like you know and
then they're resistant and there was
this another resist so I think it's
helpful to put these these these three
categories sorry like like I said before
and like the book points out from the
depression through the years of World
War two conservative Protestantism fell
into a period of cultural eclipses and
it doesn't really start to gain a lot of
speed at least in a national sense until
well after World War Two in academia in
these sort of intellectual centers of
America also early on in the media as
you know radio and television are
becoming more and more important for a
long time people of a sort of liberal
bent tended to dominate conservatives
tended to be relegated to them the
backwoods the rural areas the late time
sort of stuff they were seen as being
kind of kind of retrograde as not really
having a lot to offer that starts to
change and your book starts out by
talking originally in terms of churches
and worship and noting the difference
between the holiness and Pentecostal
denominations and the holding of some
Pentecostal denominations for the most
part until fairly recently just sort of
withdrew from from larger American life
there's some reasons why that happened
one was you know if you want to actually
be a holding district
Castle Christian you're going to be
living according to a fairly strict
moral code that's not going to allow you
to participate in quite a few things
that Americans started to see is more
and more parking homes what everybody
would do so you're probably not gonna be
dancing you're probably not going to be
listening to the radio for the
contemporary music you're probably not
going to be going to the movie theater
so this is tended to isolate them and
they were there mostly okay with that
they saw the you know the rest of
American societies can follow it and why
would you want to be involved with them
better to withdraw into your own
community fundamentalists were more
engaged with the larger community like
your buck points out and as we read
evangelicals so you get these you get
these two organizations the National
Association of Evangelicals which was an
attempt to bring together
evangelicals all across the spectrum and
then you have the American Council of
Christian churches and that was for
fundamentalist I remember fundamentalist
evangelicals not exactly the same thing
fundamentalists you know one of the key
things that's differentiating them is
not just believing that the Bible is
literally true but thinking that if
somebody else doesn't hold the
fundamentals of Christian faith you
can't have any connection with them you
can't have any fellowship with them
whereas evangelicals are more likely to
say well you reach out to them you
evangelize them so your book then talks
about this guy who you've probably heard
of but he's his important services
decline in recent years that's a Billy
Graham Graham is an interesting figure
he starts out as a very conservative
Protestant presbyterian and then he gets
ordained as a Baptist minister begins a
spirit lessons as a worker for the use
of youth for christ movement and then he
starts doing revival preaching you guys
remember the Bible's are these very
emotional you know there's sort of a
once and a wild kind of experiences when
people come together and then they just
get preached at for hours and hours and
he has to try to produce a conversion
try to produce as Billy has great Moody
had the sawdust trail you know Billy
Billy Graham expressed in terms of the
decision for Christ so you're trying to
produce this conversion experience in
people and his early preaching was very
animated
it was premillennial the end of the
world is coming you better reform quick
that are you know get good with Jesus
quick because you never know this is the
the last chance that you have as time
goes on you starts to get more and more
moderate in them before that though he
ends up not only doing all these
revivals that it calls Crusades but also
developing a radio program why is that
important think about it you know the
1940s and 50s
why was radio so important yeah yeah
even with a megaphone you know a radio
you're reaching people nationwide and
radio you know sort of like television
sort of like I mean how many of us
actually watch network television today
probably not not that many to watch
right but you do get together and talk
with your friends about what you've seen
don't you oh that's part of the fun of
watching shows isn't it
same thing happens with radium it
creates a community and he's sort of at
the Nexus of that he associated himself
and this was you know a good stance to
take in the 1950s with militant
anti-communism and he develops this real
public prominence that eventually gets
him into now becoming a politician
himself but gets him into the political
arena so that he's you know meeting
Dwight Eisenhower and then each of
Eisenhower's successors so
Kennedy Johnson Nixon and he was
actually pretty close to Nixon until
Nixon you know revealed that he indeed
was a crook you guys remember that
famous line I had not a corrector and
when it turns out that he is one of the
other problems that he had your book
talks about which makes good sense
evany never listened to these Watergate
tapes not only does Nixon like you know
reveal that all this dirty stuff is
going on he swears he uses follow filthy
language that's part of what Graham had
a problem so Graham now realizes he's
got a distance himself a bit from these
direct political involvement and
eventually he ends up the like like a
book says developing a message that can
be understood as a moderate ecumenical
evangelicalism so that's one thing going
on then your book talks about what
happened in the South and the crisis in
the south over segregation brought
brought about resistance and this took
the form of Christian academies and
Christian Academy is were basically the
code word for all white schools in the
south to avoid segmentation of what
desegregation sorry not to avoid
segregation to maintain segregation
there were some universities associated
with conservative Protestantism that
that fit into that Bob Jones University
would be an example of that they were
militantly for segregation not everybody
went that way some of the evangelicals
particularly younger people started to
argue that liberal ideas of social
justice were compatible with the
traditional theology and your book gives
a couple examples of this one is the
Jesus people of the the 60s and the 70s
who are going to lead to the new
paradigm churches that we'll talk about
another is the Campus Crusade for Christ
and it's it's why I'm going to partner
InterVarsity Christian Fellowship your
book talks about the development of
Christian yellow pages you know the
development of the whole sort of
Christian culture where Christian this
is probably a good thing to put up there
the word Christian like anything about
Christian music we're Christian
bookstores what does it really mean it
means evangelical Christians for the
most part you put then also talks about
hey Lindsey yeah and again if this were
like 10 15 years ago you guys probably
wouldn't know who he is because you'd
have seen his books and used bookstores
or some kind of time he's really
becoming just you know this historical
footnote now you wrote a book called a
late great planet Earth and you remember
we talked about dispensational
premillennialism this notion that the
end of the world is coming and you can
kind of correlate the end of the world
and the predictions about it
in the Book of Revelations in the Book
of Daniel to actual real world events
you guys remember all that sort of stuff
so it was very popular to do that in the
1970s 1980s in terms of what Reagan
later called the evil empire what was
that exactly
and their allies the Warsaw Pact and so
you know battle of armageddon was
supposed to be us squaring off against
the Soviets probably in his Rio or
something like that well you know it's
hard to make those sort of correlations
after the Soviet Union Falls then it's
got to be China or maybe iran or whoever
else will let it behind series that'd be
a more contemporary example of this kind
of apocalyptic literature
it's way into the popular culture I'm
gonna read the Left Behind books
those are in that same sort of sort of
genre so we're going to come back to
culture and when we get some new church
structure in a few minutes I'm going to
run really quickly because we don't have
a hell of a lot of time through talking
about politics and the religious right
what do we mean when we talk about the
religious right does that meet all
Republicans it's a good question the
Republicans are the conservative party
the Democrats of the liberal force right
if we're very broadly speaking at this
time does that mean that all Republicans
are religious are all people who are
conservative and religious Republicans
matter of fact they they sometimes you
could say that it's a good number Venn
diagrams from like logic classes so
here's Republicans and here's
conservatives and here's you know
traditional Christians they don't have
these coincide with each other yeah part
of what you have to do is you're a
political party and you actually want to
win elections is you have to find ways
to like pull things into your spot your
Venn diagram publicans do this and the
Democrats do this very well that's
whether the two dominant parties nobody
else really does a good job at that
that's a long conversation why that's
the case
in general in the 1980s of the 1990s you
could say that there was a strong
alignment between
additional Christians conservative
Christians and the Republican Party and
it actually went down through churches
as well you know churches that don't
have an explicitly political bed like
the Catholic Church where it's really
split you know
Democrat Republican the more
conservative Catholics voted for Bush
overwhelmingly the more liberal
Catholics voted for a carry to elections
so there's a number of different issues
that your book talks about and we'll
just mention a few of them like you know
the gay rights issue is a huge one right
now but what were to some of the other
bigger issues before the abortion that's
a perennial issue that comes up and what
else worry about what they call
secularization or secular humanism that
was a big concern back in the 1980s
family patterns was poverty caused by
all these sorts of things they all get
tied up in the political field yeah what
we've seen in recent elections is that
conservative Christians seem to be
getting less and less happy with the
Republicans but they don't really have
anywhere else to go
because the Democratic Party doesn't
appeal to them very well it espouses a
number of positions that they they tend
to find an apartment like you know
supporting abortion but the Republicans
don't seem to be particularly good at
delivering on this and many of the
Republicans seem to be willing to sort
of gloss over that so it's kind of an
open question right now one say actually
is there a religious right what's going
to happen with the religious right we're
no longer in the same condition that we
were back in the 1980s and 90s where
there was a very strong alignment where
you know you might say more like like
this
last thing I got a very great way and
I'm just gonna throw words up here
let's televangelism Skycam a bad name
your book mentions a lot of the scandals
that took place in the eighties late
eighties and early nineties what is
televangelism it's still around today
you flip around the channel those of you
that still watch cable TV you'll come
across some telepath tell evangelizing
channels it's sort of like what you know
Billy Graham was doing with the radio
only with with TV and a lot of them will
you know it's very kind of spun sort of
style to it I guess is probably enough
to say about this we would probably talk
about more what's a megachurch what is
that
yeah okay so giant building yeah there's
actually one that's talked about in the
book now in this chapter but another one
that has you can park your car and just
like with you know drive-in movie
theaters you can listen to the sermon on
your radio that's pretty huge know why
you support these mega churches they
find something relevant there tends to
be more contemporary music a lot of the
old media techniques these have become
pretty big most of them were in the
south
but there's one that's in Chicago that's
been there for a long time yeah use
these drugs right a few a lot of love
these are actually connected with what
we call the new paradigm this is what
we'll end with
so when you talk about a new paradigm
what do you need that new paradigm for
marketing there's a new way of thinking
of that new paradigm churches were
designed to reach out to me remember
this term we've used before the
unchurched for people who weren't
getting their needs met by traditional
religion and they would do market
analyses and trying to figure out how
can we actually bring the unchurched or
mostly younger people how can we make
Christianity of y'all event to them so
some of that is connected with the mega
church phenomenon a lot of this will be
smaller non-denominational churches or
it'll be like vineyard churches
contemporary music very contemporary
service I would be overdressed at a
church like that even preaching
everything supposed to be very informal
right